Christophe Blanchet pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chargé la
transition numérique Jean-Noël Barrault
tout d'abord au nom du groupe démocrate
permettez-moi de vous féliciter pour
votre brillant trait élection ce weekend
dans la deuxième circonscription des
Yvelines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là encore de nombreux services et leurs
fichiers sont touchés dans l'ensemble
des démarches concernant les allocations
pour l'autonomie et le handicap
totalement indisponible nous avons des
pays suspects sur la provenance des
attaques et à l'heure de la guerre en
Ukraine nous savons que le cyber fait
partie des armes modernes de
déstabilisation avec des organisations
criminelles qui s'organisent en
industrie de la cyber aussi comment
peut-on mieux protéger notre tissu
économique nos hôpitaux et nos
collectivités face à ces attaques
massives qui deviennent de plus en plus
récurrentes et qui constituent un butin
conséquent et précieux pour ces réseaux
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Christophe Blanchet d'abord soyez
remercier pour vos félicitations ce
résultat sonne comme un encouragement à
poursuivre le travail engagé sur
l'autorité du Président de la République
de la première ministre dans le dialogue
dans le compromis dans le respect de
l'institution des institutions cela va
sans dire mais semble-t-il ça va mieux
en le disant et toujours au service de
l'intérêt général vous m'interrogez
monsieur le député au sujet de l'attaque
brutal qui a frappé le Département de
Seine-Maritime dimanche dernier j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec le président Bélanger
et je veux saluer la réponse exemplaire
qui a été apportée par les équipes du
département qui ont sollicité les
autorités compétentes dans les minutes
qui ont suivi le début de l'attaque
comme 700 collectivités le Département
de Seine-Maritime était entrée dans un
parcours de sécurisation dispensé par
l'ansy dans le cadre du plan de relance
qui a certainement contribué à limiter
les conséquences dramatique de cette
attaque mais comme vous le rappelez ce
qui s'est passé à l'hôpital de Dax à
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes à la
mairie de Caen et dimanche dernier au
Département de Seine-Maritime nous
rappelle que la cybercriminalité est une
grande menace de notre temps que la
criminalité la délinquance migre dans
l'espace numérique de douve que nous
devons tout mettre en œuvre et redoubler
nos efforts pour apporter une réponse à
cette menace
prévention répression remédiation c'est
ainsi que nous voulons avec Bruno Le
Maire répondre à cette nouvelle menace
avec Lanci qui fait un travail
remarquable d'accompagnement et de
remédiation et que la première ministre
a décidé de renforcer dans ses effectifs
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finance 2023 avec cyber
maveillance.gouv.fr qui accompagne des
dizaines de milliers de victimes
collectivités entreprises particuliers
chaque jour dites-le autour de vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés en cas
de doute cyber malveillance.gouv.fr avec
la locmi qui est présentée aujourd'hui
par le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui sera examiné prochainement par votre
assemblée bref vous l'avez entendu nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés pour
apporter une réponse à cette menace